foreign
[Music]
me
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show where today we ask the eternal
question
wubble lubba dub dub or wubba lubba sub
sub
since we're talking about rick and morty
the anime you see the team behind rick
and morty just dropped an anime short
their second mini anime episode of the
year in fact and
normally this wouldn't be the sort of
thing that i would dedicate an entire
episode to it's a fun little spin-off
episode to keep the fandom engaged
sure fine whatever get a few extra views
for your adult swim youtube channel get
a bit more promotion to keep rick and
morty on everyone's minds in the
entertainment wasteland that is 20 20.
yeah i get it you gotta run on that
content treadmill rick and morty but
here's why i'm dedicating a theory to
these anime shorts
i think they're important or at least i
think this latest one
is important to the overall canon of the
show so much so that i think it might be
hinting at answers to the biggest
mysteries
left remaining in this franchise
including the history of rick sanchez
and his past
relationship with evil morty no joke
rick and morty may have just told us
everything we need to know about evil
morty in an eight minute
made for digital anime which come to
think of it probably isn't the strangest
thing that this franchise has ever done
so
i read that line as if i'm surprised but
should i be you see the first anime
short titled samurai and shogun was
released in the before
times back in march of 2020 and follows
a different rick from the dimension
wtm-72 it's extremely cool
and extremely bloody but there's not a
whole lot of substance beyond our
characters riffing on old samurai movies
like lone wolf and cub
no it's the second one here that really
matters released
just a few weeks ago rick and morty
versus genocider explicitly calls out
that we're watching the adventures of
c137 rick yes
unlike the previous anime short which
intentionally distanced itself from the
action of the show by pulling a random
rick from a random universe completely
disconnected from what we watch on tv
this one very specifically is drawing
our attention to the fact that this is
c137 rick and it's more than just a fun
action rom
it's drawing on the events and themes
and most importantly the characters of
the canon of rick and morty the tv
series
but first a bit of an explainer of what
this video is all about and i know that
explainer portions of videos can
sometimes come across as something that
youtubers do to pan out the runtime but
believe me
this video needs the explainer if the
number of wtf did i just watch comments
that this thing has gotten is anything
to go by the short opens with morty at
the citadel of ricks this
video seems to take place after the
tales of the citadel episode from season
3 because it appears that everything is
under the control of evil morty who
if you recall won the citadel election
at the end of that episode before
promptly eliminating all his opposition
now
is the time for action
and if there's any doubt that this is
evil morty well the end of the episode
gives us even more evidence but
we'll come to that in a second morty
worried that rick is being hunted by a
group called the genociders heads off to
tokyo to find him as he walks around
tokyo we see people starting to
disappear we're told that this is all
part of the genocider's plan
destroy life by altering people's
memories we're shown a moment where rick
explains to morty that reality as we
know it
is simply the state formed by the
consensus of human memory
if i can translate what i think this
means the past only exists because
people remember and agree to certain
events having happened
without that consensus the past is
nothing it's nebulous
it disappears those past memories then
are like points on a graph you connect
those together to find out where you are
currently that is yourself in the
present and if you follow that line
forward
you're projecting out to create a target
for your future but without those past
memories to guide the way to form a
foundation upon which the present and
future are built
everything collapses which i presume is
why people are disappearing from the
cities
morty eventually makes his way to the
last place in tokyo that's still humming
the seediest place in the city
shinjuku kabukicho for those who don't
know kabukicho is indeed a real place
the entertainment
and more importantly red light district
of shinjuku tokyo a place filled with
hosts and hostess clubs and the sort of
hotels that charge you by the hour
it also has a really awesome robot
restaurant with a really catchy theme
song that plays at
all hours of the night where you descend
down into a basement to watch
animatronics create fire hazards literal
feet from your face
i did a video all about that over on
game theory you can watch it in 360 in
fact that was uh that was a wild night
anyway it's not really explained how
this is the one part of the city where
there's still people maybe it's because
people living in tokyo's so-called
sleepless town are always forming new
memories or maybe it's because they're
boozing it up so hard that they never
had any memories to begin with but at
any rate this place definitely sounds
like rick's idea of a good time so it
comes as no surprise when morty is able
to find him there
rick gives morty a vial of some blue
potion saying
once i'm gone take this it'll make you
rip van winkle
referencing the old american folk tale
about a man who drinks a mysterious
potion
falls into a deep slumber for 20 years
and then wakes up to a completely
different world
at least that's what the english
subtitles are saying if you listen to
the original spoken japanese dialogue
rick
actually tells morty that drinking the
vilo turn him into arashima taro
here i'll play it for you did you hear
it hiroshima taro is a character from an
old japanese folk tale about a fisherman
who leaves home on a fantastical
adventure and returns to discover that a
hundred years have passed in his absence
it's similar to rip van winkle but with
a few
important distinctions make a note of
that we'll come back to it in a minute
anyway rick explains that the potion is
made
with the secretions from the alien brain
parasites that we saw in the season two
episode total rickal
in case you forgot this iconic episode
it's the episode where the smith family
has to deal with alien parasites that
reproduce by creating false memories
which manifest themselves
as new alien parasites it's also the
episode where everyone's favorite mr
poopybutthole was first introduced so
again the important detail here is that
rick gives morty a blue potion that's
somehow related to memory
and memory replication at this point
rick leaves morty to go fight the
genociders
[Music]
an explosion rocks the building rick is
sent flying and a bunch of portals open
up revealing an army of ricks of course
our rick isn't bothered by this from his
perspective everything is unfolding
exactly according to kaikaku
rick unleashes his powers to become
ultra instinct rick in an epic anime
battle ensues the battle ends with an
explosion that annihilates everyone
which reveals that the main genocider
rick was
actually a robot all along a robot
controlled by none other
than evil morty back at the citadel this
whole moment is a call back to the first
time we were introduced to evil morty
back in season one
in the episode close rick counters of
the rick kind when evil rick is revealed
to be surprise surprise a robot notice
the exact same mechanism behind their
eyes and we cut to the reveal of evil
morty who is controlling him via remote
in his eye patch
and in yet another parallel in both the
anime and the episode
evil morty crushes the controller under
his foot
in short the whole genocider threat was
created by evil morty to get r
morty to expose rick c-137's hiding
place and while the assassination team
might be dead so is c-137 and apparently
that's good enough news for evil morty
mission complete
or is it as evil morty leaves the
control room an image of rick appears
behind him
taunting him um
he turns around and rick is nowhere to
be seen was rick's taunt merely a
hallucination or something more again
i'm getting to that let's just finish
describing this thing we've got like
less than a minute left in the aftermath
of the battle we cut to a shot of a
silhouetted figure wearing a lab coat
receiving a voicemail from jerry
reaching out to his dear old
father-in-law
the figure who we can only presume to be
rick based on his profile
reaches for that familiar hip flask
except when he places it back down it's
shown not to be the hip flask but the
vial of memory potion that rick had
given morty earlier in the episode
roll that jojo meme
[Music]
so as you can see there's a lot to
unpack here i'm gonna present two
possible interpretations of this one
that seems to be among the more popular
theories floating around the internet
and the other
of which is my personal theory one that
i think meshes best with what we're
shown both inside the anime short as
well as the rick and morty series as a
whole
the first interpretation is this at the
end when rick fights against the
assassination squad and dies
morty takes the blue memory potion this
not only allows morty to absorb rick's
memories but
physically transforms him into rick from
there
morty with his newly acquired rick
memories rebuilds
japan as we saw in the anime battle the
entire city got destroyed so it's up to
morty as the new rick to reset the world
back to a time 14 years before when
morty was born he does this
somehow the video kind of hand waves
this away but you know it's rick he has
hundreds of backup plans for these sorts
of situations
anyway with the city now reset to where
it was 14 years ago by morty rick the
cycle begins anew and the events of the
past begin repeating themselves it's a
time loop story except without any
actual time travel because as we know
rick and his creators always talk about
how much they hate time travel
i mean he even mentions it in this
episode
one strong piece of evidence supporting
this theory is that rick tells morty
that drinking the memory potion will
turn him into arashima taro
in the old folk tale arashimataro is a
fisherman who rescues a turtle and as a
reward the turtle takes him on a magical
adventure down to the dragon palace
beneath the sea
there he meets with princess otoime and
spends what he believes to be several
days there eventually he asks to go back
home and is given a mysterious jeweled
box
the princess tells him that the box will
protect him but that he shouldn't open
it
taro returns home and discovers that
although only a few days have passed for
him
more than a hundred years have passed
back home
everyone and everything that he
remembered from his home village is gone
when he opens the forbidden jeweled box
that he was given by the princess he
becomes an
old man now a lot of things fit here
mostly the idea that when morty drinks
the potion he literally becomes an old
man he becomes his grandfather
rick after all rick did tell him that
the potion when consumed would turn
morty into arashima taro
maybe he meant it a bit more literally
than any of us could have imagined a
similar but slightly different
interpretation is that morty isn't
transformed into
rick by the potion so much as he
naturally grows up to become rick that
this final scene isn't a time loop or
anything like that but rather a shot
from many years later when morty
is himself an old man in other words
what we know of as
rick is just an old grown-up morty morty
survives the battle against the
genociders and goes on with his life
at some point he drinks the potion and
gains rick's memories but it does
nothing to him physically
morty just grows up and lives out his
life the idea that morty grows up to
become his own grandfather
or that rick is just an older version of
morty is certainly a strange one and
certainly a bit confusing but it's one
that's supported by
imagery in this episode right before
rick goes off to the fight we see a
momentary shot where the camera fades
between a shot of morty's face and rix
overlapping now that might seem like
it's just a stylistic thing but to me
it's clearly the animators telling us
that these two separate people
are actually one and the same now this
would have itself a few interesting
consequences
one it allows morty to stay safe
avoiding the murderous intent of evil
morty who clearly has it out for c-137
or any of his descendants
two it aligns with the last words that
rick tells morty before he goes off to
the fight
i
rick in this moment knows that morty
will grow up to become him
they'll certainly have more adventures
together but this time morty will be in
the role of rick
it's a coy double answer and three it's
something that's actually been
alluded to in the show before in that
tales of the citadel episode again we
see the school where they train up
mortys and who do we have in class with
the mortys a dumb
rick did i graduate this time yet back
then it got people's minds working if a
dumb rick is the equivalent of an
up-and-coming morty could there be
more to this connection here this anime
seems to suggest
yes because here's the thing theorists
regardless of the mechanism whether it's
transformation or natural age
one thing that seems undeniable is that
morty becomes
rick so the question is is any of this
canon
well i think so the anime short goes a
long way to reference specific moments
and characters from throughout the tv
series
explicitly naming this rick as r-rick
c-137
all the visual parallels to evil morty
and his robotic rick
outright calling out season two in the
memory parasites i mean remember if
their goal was to just tell a fun rick
and morty themed story
it would have been very easy for them to
do what the other anime short from
earlier this year did and just tell us
that this
rick was from a different dimension but
they actively
didn't do that so that is already a huge
possible revelation here but i think
there's one more thing remember that
hallucination that evil morty had of
rick
it shows a familiarity a past
relationship evil morty hallucinating
c-137 rick trolling him
shows an inferiority complex a
psychological need to prove to this
specific
rick that he's better that he's smarter
he's more capable and that doesn't make
sense
unless as many have already suspected
this morty is rick's
original morty one thing that's gone
under discussed in videos about evil
morty is that he
actively targets rick c137 throughout
the tv series
in his first appearance his plan is to
frame rick c137 for the murder of all
the other ricks that way the council of
ricks punishes him
by death the plan doesn't work and here
again we see evil morty despite having
already taken over the citadel still
targeting this specific rick why is he
afraid that rick might take him out
doesn't really make sense rick doesn't
care about anything as long as he's left
alone no
this morty has a personal vendetta
against c137 rick he wants to poke the
beehive
he has something to prove he wants to
see this rick
suffer it's the mortiest morty versus
the rickest rick evil morty appears to
be rick's original morty which as we
just learned is
also kind of himself talking about rick
and morty gets to be kind of weird
sometimes of course
all of these lore bits and relationships
between the characters are contingent on
it actually being canon and while i do
think that all signs point yes i
wouldn't put it past the show's creators
to one day say that this was made by an
entirely different writing team and
therefore
nothing in the anime is canon i don't
want to see any more anime
stuff happening to my son buster which
means that until
season five it's all just a theory a
film
theory and cut
[Music]
you